in good shape your weekly dose of health
information on Deutsche Welle find out
more about what's new in medical
treatment alternative medicine as well
as nutrition wellness and beauty medical
professionals therapists and counselors
are in our studio to offer their expert
advice on in good shape when our
varicose veins - really enough to go to
the doctor that's what I will be
discussing with my guests
vascular specialist dr. Engel lessen
Campbell welcome to the studio hi hello
when do varicose veins actually need
treatment oh they need treatment if they
cause symptoms that's it
not every wayne that you see on your leg
has to be treated but if they do cause
symptoms and then they may harm your
deep venous system and then they should
be treated and where do they come from
we've got a facebook friend Lafayette
Hammond
living in New Zealand and he wants to
know if lifestyle is something to do
with it or more genes and something to
do with that oh it's just both okay the
one thing is our western lifestyle we
don't move enough and we are sitting to
March we are standing to March and it's
better to move that's one thing the
other thing is that for for sure there
are some genetic dispositions and
everybody knows that there are some
families you know which several members
already have some varicose veins and
what about obesity is a high body weight
and contributing to varicose veins yes
but that starts from a certain level
it's not smart overweight is not really
causing wear cuz winds but if you really
Opie's then it might be a cause to
reduce the weight okay and into all
various wanes need treatment at some
point in life now I think so we know
people that have real varicose veins
that you see and that don't cause any
symptoms and then you don't have to
treat them but if they are already
changing the color of your skin on the
then you should treat them anyway and if
they cause symptoms as well and let's
talk a bit about different kinds of
varicose veins what about spider veins
those small bluish shares of means
others actually varicose veins yes they
are but most times they are just a
cosmetic point of view and very rarely
is a cause burning feeling and then we
treat them for sure but most times it's
just cosmetic but if you have lots of
spiders on your legs then they might be
a sign of more important varicose veins
which are situated below them and they
cause a high Persian skin and cause
spiders and then you should treat them
as well and what about the wings we call
hemorrhoids we've got a question from
Poland claudia young coughs conselho are
hemorrhoids varicose veins they are a
special kind of varicose veins but they
very rarely have the same origin and
normally they're treated by other
physicians what are the warning signs in
general before you can actually see the
vein coming out are there any warning
signs you can see it on your leg
warning signs on your legs might be
spiders as I said before but most times
there are symptoms symptoms and form of
a swelling of your of your calves a
swelling that increases over the H I'm
in mourning it's a way again and start
in the afternoon that's a warning sign
that might be over it goes away and then
we do have a viewer who actually has one
varicose vein and it's called Maximilian
Lewis Brockhaus from Chile and he said
he's a very healthy person he's doing
sports and so on his healthy lifestyle
and he got one singular varicose vein
and on his leg what you say about that
I'm sorry for him but I think he has
just had bad luck yeah I suppose he has
done everything right and if varicose
vein appears on this age probably there
is a genetic disposition and it should
be treated done we've just seen
radiofrequency ablation and stripping
but there are also other methods and
treating varicose veins
could you just outline them for us yeah
I think there are three classes of
treatments in the first class we'll just
have those methods that we call Chairman
a plaintiff methods its laser its
radiofrequency is a long outreach and
there are many more and they all have
the same structure and they heat in the
rain and destroy some structures in the
wall the way in concentrates and
disappears after a while in the second
class we have the open operation and
it's kind of stripping and stripping is
done in a very you know quite a lot of
variations and in the third class we
have glue we have foam sclerotherapy and
so on we call them chemotherapies you
know and if there are so many different
methods on the market how do I find as a
patient how would I find the right
method for me oh I think as a patient
it's almost impossible to find out which
method is just appropriate for myself
and so I will go to an institution where
several methods are available and then
the expert should look for just in view
individual appropriate method for this
patient and are the differences in the
risk and side-effects between all those
methods I think all these mothers have
very few risks the side effects differ a
little bit betweens and methods that the
level of side-effects is almost the same
and if I would start treatment very
early in an early stage of the varicose
veins is it and the better outcome then
can I perhaps sometimes skip an
operation altogether no I think we
should look for an operation or any
treatment any invasive treatment in
relation to the concerns in relation to
the symptoms if there are as few or no
symptoms you shouldn't treat the veins
okay and how good our alternative
therapies are not going into the Oh are
and perform some surgery what do you
think of leeches for example leeches
they do harm and say they won't treat a
very costly and they
really don't help - that's workers veins
will disappear
yes they are used for trauma phlebitis
but that's just another thing and even
there they can do harm and what about
oil moons and capsules you could get in
a pharmacy do they help for varicose
veins pointment are not known to really
help but we have some substances and
capsules which are extracts from
chestnut and they really help but not to
everyone and we have to look who could
try them yeah and who not you have just
to test them and next to the ointments
and and capsules can you do anything at
home without seeing a doctor to treat
varicose veins if you have varicose
veins you can move a lot yeah I couldn't
activate your lifestyle and your for
instance you can take cold showers for
your legs but really you can just give
relief to the symptoms and not make
dissapears veins our viewer Nick og from
Great Britain has the same problem like
I do we both sit with our having our
legs crossed is this sitting position
and harmful to the veins and can this
lead to varicose veins I think it can't
lead to varicose veins as you are done
sitting all your life in this position
or here and it's made maybe it's not the
favorite position part I think they
don't ruin your veins okay so this is a
safe way to sit thank you so much doctor
pleasant kappa for being with us in this
do - thank you for being here
you